Robert Downey jr. has been a fixture in
Hollywood longer than many of his fans
have been alive while his talent and
charisma have always been undeniable he
was long plagued by off-screen troubles
that threatened to sink his career but
over the last decade he's experienced a
personal and professional resurgence
that has him on top of the world and
Hollywood's a-list
it's not easy to go from high-school
dropout to founding member of the
Avengers but showbiz and struggle have
been in Downey's blood from the
beginning underground dad
Downey's irreverence self-deprecating
humor and anti-authoritarian streak made
a lot of sense if you're familiar with
his father Robert Downey seniors started
writing and directing independent films
in the early 1960s his first film to
receive a wide release was the 1969
satire Putney Swope the story of a black
man accidentally put in charge of an
advertising agency Jr made his film
debut as a five-year-old in his dad's
1970 movie pound in which all the actors
play dogs that tornado scared me so much
it made my head disappear
have any hammer on you ball a year later
Downey senior led his six-year-old son
try marijuana for the first time which
Downey senior later came to greatly
regret when his parents divorced in 1978
a 13 year old junior followed his dad
from New York to LA at the age of 16 he
dropped out of high school to pursue
acting full-time New York beginnings
rather than attempt to break into
Hollywood the teenage down he returned
to his mother's in New York he landed
roles in a couple of small productions
including 1984's firstborn a little
remembered drama co-starring an eighteen
year old Sarah Jessica Parker the two
hit it off immediately beginning a
relationship that would last for years
even as down he became a mainstay on the
New York party scene in 1985 down he
joined the cast of Saturday Night Live
producer Lorne Michaels had just
returned to the show after five years
away and he hired an entirely new cast
it became painfully apparent that Downey
was out of his element that simply
represents a dramatic synthesis of the
much of the new cast failed to click
with each other and Downey was among
those who work and at the end of the
season professional success personal
troubles the sacking from SNL was a
blessing in disguise as it coincided
with the rise of Downey's film career he
had small roles in the John Hughes films
weird science and pretty and pink as
well as the Rodney Dangerfield comedy
back to school
1987 brought two highlights his first
lead role in the pickup artist and less
than zero his most critically acclaimed
performance to date less than 0 featured
Downey as the hard-partying cocaine
addict julianne wells
it earned him recognition as a serious
actor but the experience of making it
had some very unfortunate repercussions
drugs had virtually always been a part
of Downey's life but he's pointed to
less than zero as the time when the
troubles really began he explained to
the Guardian the character was an
exaggeration of myself then things
changed and in some ways I became an
exaggeration of the character that
lasted far longer than it needed to last
the a-list the 1992 biopic Chaplin
cemented Downey's reputation as a
critically acclaimed actor his
performances screen legend Charlie
Chaplin made him one of the most
in-demand stars in Hollywood and earned
him a Best Actor Oscar nomination he
followed that up with acclaim turns and
Robert Altman's short cuts in 1993 and
Oliver Stone's Natural Born Killers in
1994 his personal life was also looking
up as he married actress Deborah
Falconer in 1992 and they had a son two
years later but his troubles with
addiction would soon boil over nearly
losing it all in June 1996 Downey was
arrested for felony cocaine and heroin
possession after being pulled over for
driving while completely naked in Malibu
a few weeks later an extremely confused
neighbor found the actor cozily tucked
into bed in one of his guestrooms
numerous trips to rehab seemed to do
nothing to quell his habit and his film
roles diminished in size and frequency
as the arrests piled up a brief comeback
on the hit TV series Ally McBeal was
derailed by more drug charges in 2001 he
appeared on The Oprah Winfrey Show in
2004 and spoke about his struggles it's
not that difficult to overcome these
seemingly ghastly problems you are
saying that it's
that difficult know what's hardest to
decide cleaning up his act
Downey's marriage to Falconer ended in
divorce in 2004 but he had just met
producer Susan Levin the year before on
the set of Gothika and things turned
serious pretty quickly but Levin let it
be known that she wouldn't marry Downey
unless he gave up drugs completely this
was the final nail in the coffin for his
old life in the two married in 2005 with
a newfound focus and sobriety came an
uptick in the number of interesting
roles offered to Downey well received
turns in Kiss Kiss Bang Bang good night
and good luck
and A Scanner Darkly culminated in a
supporting role in the 2007 thriller
zodiac one of the most acclaimed films
of that year the role of a lifetime 2008
Iron Man has been called in retrospect
the riskiest film in history by the time
of its release Marvel had been planning
that all of its future films would take
place in the same shared universe with
characters crossing over between films
Iron Man set the tone for this universe
essentially selling the whole concept of
the MCU to film goers much of this
depended upon its leading man and if the
film had flopped Downey's career might
have recovered but Marvel likely never
would have but of course the film was a
smash hit with critics and audiences
alike and among all of the praise Downey
was singled out for inhabiting his
character in a way that few superhero
movie leads have done before or since
the MCU has gone on to become the
highest-grossing film franchise of all
time and Downey has been its face from
the very beginning while he's also
continued to snag an Oscar nomination
for 2008 Tropic Thunder and to create a
popular new spin on Sherlock Holmes it's
become increasingly difficult to tell
where Downey ends and start begins truth
is
I am Iron Man